- À chacun son effort de guerre.
Dans cette cuisine de Lviv,
dedes milliers de repas
sont préparés chaque jour
pour les Ukrainiens déplacés.
Des plats nourrissants,
mais surtout réconfortants.
"Les gens qui fuient l'est
du pays ont besoin d'un bon
repas chaud", dit ce chef.
Après plus de sept semaines
de guerre, la mobilisationntntnt
aussi.
Tous les jours, de nouveaux
dans ce centre d'hébergement.
Des gens fuyant les violences
de l'est de l'Ukraine.
Vlad a eu beaucoup de cecece.
Il a profité d'une accalmie dans
les tirs d'artillerie russe pour
r r r r Sievierodonetsk avec
des proches. Sa ville est située
dans le Donbass sur la ligne
je connais y sont toujours.
Certains ne veulent pas
s'en aller. Ils disent que
c'est leur destin d'y rester.
D'autres, explique-t-il,
de transport pour s'échapper."
séparent Yuliia, 17 ans,
de son amoureux. Il a insi
pour qu'elle quitte la région de
Louhansk alors que lui est resté
derrière pour prend-d-d-d-d-d-ds
blessée parce que des obus
aiaiaiaiaient devant ma maison."
Quand on lui demande si elle
veut retourner chez elle...
... l'émotion est impossible
à contenir. Elle espère que
sa maison et les autres seront
pourront rentrer chez eux.
Mais l'intensification des
fait craindre le pire. Vlad ne
se fait pas d'illusions.
"Il ne faut pas paniquer.
Cela va durer un temps,
on ne peut pas y échapper",
dit-il, résigné.
Qu'ils soient jeunes ou plus
âgés, les déplacés ukrainiens
portent le même poids, celui
de l'exil et de l'incertitude. ,
Radio